like many adaptations Netflix's bird box
underwent a number of changes on its
journey from the page to the screen and
some of them are pretty surprising
loosen your blindfold and take a look at
some of the biggest differences between
the book and film versions of bird box
the bird box book takes a slow burn
approach to the apocalypse with the
spread of the monsters unfolding over a
span of months the movie speeds things
up dramatically compressing much of the
chaos into a single afternoon in the
book Malory doesn't join up with other
survivors until three months after
America starts seeing a wave of
mysterious deaths instead she and her
sister Shannon whose name was changed to
Jessica for the movie first takes
shelter together in a rented home they
share the sisters board up the house
watching the news and listening to the
radio for updates on the outside world
at first
Mallory's not even sure if the monsters
are real only becoming convinced when
they inspire her sister to take her own
life in the movie Jessica sees one of
the monsters as she's driving causing
her to crash the car and walk into
traffic before Mallory's eyes in the
book Shannon dies more quietly inside
the sisters house when a window becomes
exposed while Mallory's in another room
whatever Shannon sees inspires her to
fatally stabbed herself with a pair of
scissors it's only at this point that
Mallory becomes convinced the monsters
are real after which she finally decides
to leave and seek out the help of others
in the movie
Mallory finds refuge in a house with a
group of strangers with whom she hides
out for a couple of weeks in the book
though she sticks with this group for
roughly half a year and it's a pretty
different group to many of the books
survivors were replaced with new
creations for the movie these characters
included Charlie the supermarket
employee and aspiring novelist Greg the
owner of the house and Lucy a young
woman who teams up with Felix to steal
the group's own the car John Malkovich's
Douglas shares a few traits with a
character from the book named done with
both men being blunt cynical and
concerned about the group's limited
resources he's one of the movie's most
entertaining elements and for the most
part he's made up and what are they
gonna do a Greg start better than the
Ness both versions of bird box feature
the characters Tom and Gary with Gary's
role as an agent of the monsters
staying more or less the same but Tom
played by trivanti Rhodes has a much
bigger role in the movie than he does in
the book in the novel Tom is a blue eyed
sandy haired man who dies Wood Gary
betrays the survivors never becoming
romantically involved with Mallory in
the movie
Tom manages to kill Gary keeping him
from hurting Mallory and the newborn
kids afterwards he spends five years
living with Mallory in another location
acting as a husband to her and a father
to the two children before sacrificing
himself to protect them all bird boxes
creatures are a threat in both versions
of the story but the movie makes the
monsters much more malicious in the film
there's no doubt that the monsters are
trying to hurt people while the book is
a little bit more ambiguous one notable
example occurs during the river journey
when Mallory and the kids run into a
monster in the book the creature
attempts to take off Mallory's blindfold
but actually backs off when Mallory
protests it's implied in the book that
the monsters aren't necessarily evil
they're more of a force of nature that
neither the characters nor the reader is
able to totally understand the movie
monsters act more traditionally
villainous attempting to manipulate
people with psychological tricks like
faking human voices despite these
differences
neither the book nor the movie actually
show what the monsters look like which
in the movies case is a pretty good
thing considering the silly design they
almost went with in both versions of
bird box birds serve a purpose as
warning signs for people like Canaries
in a coal mine indicating the danger is
close in the movie the birds are
helpfully immune to the monsters but in
the book animals are as vulnerable to
the creatures as people are making them
less useful for survival the movie
presents Mallory's birds as an essential
asset for the river journey but in the
book the birds die before she even
starts the trip in one sequence during
the voyage an entire flock of birds
falls victim to the monsters causing
bird bodies and blood to rain down
around the
for a while in the book Malory also
keeps a border collie named Victor with
her as a seeing-eye dog it's clever
arrangement that ends in tragedy when
Victor is exposed to one of the monsters
he reacts by fatally chewing off his own
legs one of the most intense points in
the movie comes when Malory and the kids
encounter Rapids on the river knowing
that her death would doom the children
Mallory tells the kids that one of them
will have to take off their blindfold
and act as her navigator before her
change of heart its heavily implied that
Mallory is going to choose girl to make
the sacrifice potentially dooming
Olivia's daughter while sparing her
biological child
somebody has to look Ella no I will
decide okay I will decide Jimmy's just
give me a second while it's one of the
most suspenseful parts of the movie this
moral dilemma is completely avoided in
the book where Mallory asserts that
she'll be the one to take off her
blindfold don't be fooled though the
book version of Mallory is still a
pretty intense parent both versions of
bird box end with Mallory and her kids
reaching a safe haven but the lead-up to
their journey has big differences in the
movie Mallory and Tom learn of the
potential refuge from a mysterious voice
on the radio
Tom is optimistic about the new
information the Mallory is skeptical
it's only after Tom's death that Mallory
is pushed into making the journey in the
book
Mallory knows about the sanctuary for
years and raises her children with the
goal of eventually seeking it out
she vigorously trains the children for
the journey from a very young age
teaching them to keep their eyes closed
and identify sounds to the point that
their senses of hearing surpass hers
sometimes her training takes an
uncomfortably brutal approach with
Mallory punishing the children for
opening their eyes by hitting them with
flyswatters when their babies she even
briefly considers blinding them with
paint thinner so if you thought movie
Mallory was hard to sympathize with just
now it could have been so much worse
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you